Yes. Hello world. It's Saroj and
it might seem counterintuitive,
but machine learning can actually help
make dating more enjoyable and improve
the quality of human relationships.
Specifically,
AI is currently being used in several
dating apps to help people spend less time
swiping and more quality time in person,
as well as helping discover optimally
compatible partners. In this video,
I'm going to explain how three Ai
Techniques, collaborative filtering,
image classification and language modeling
can automate the boring parts of the
dating pipeline to help you find
compatible matches much faster.
Ai Helps you get laid seriously.
It might surprise you to find out that
millennial spend about 10 hours a week on
dating apps and while the dating app
industry continually earns more revenue
every year,
many users have developed a love hate
relationship with these algorithms.
Dating apps have indeed made it
easier to find potential partners,
but they've also exposed
users to a host of new issues,
spending time mindlessly swiping,
dealing with texts that are superficial,
hurtful, and disappointing. Ghosting,
cat phishing, fake profiles,
getting matched with Matlab users put
together these negative aspects of online
dating have contributed to feelings of
anxiety and depression amongst users.
And the reality is that today more people
meet through online dating platforms
than off one technology
has already fundamentally
changed the nature of dating.
The question then becomes how can AI
help improve this experience? Sex robot,
Bro, I've got this in a way,
dating is all about data.
You spend time with another cumin, then
use that experience for data collection.
You then analyze that data to make
decisions like whether or not to see that
person again.
And we can in fact break down this
data science pipeline into three parts.
Discovery, first impressions and
intimacy. So let's start with discovery.
The popular dating app hinge found out
that only one in 500 swipes led to an
exchange of phone numbers, meaning the
time required to find a suitable match.
It's still quite a while.
And depending on where you live,
your potential pool of dating partners
can be anywhere from a few hundred to a
few million people. And if
you're picky like me, just one,
we need a way of automatically filtering
out all those options and presenting
users with the best one.
If Amazon can recommend products and
Netflix can recommend movies with machine
learning,
dating apps should theoretically be also
be able to harness the power of data
and algorithms to help
users find optimal matches.
One example of this is hinges recently
released feature titled Most compatible
that automatically sends users
one recommended match per day.
The way it does this is by using a
technique called content which provides
recommendations based on shared
preferences between users.
In the context of dating apps, it's
actually hard to find a paper on this.
Usually recommender system papers focus
on recommending products, not people,
but I did find one that details
and approach called recon.
The idea is that for each user we
built a distribution for every profile
attribute in order to
model their preferences.
Things like ASM or and
artists and all toast.
These distributions are aggregated based
on profiles that the user has indicated
interest towards via his or her
messaging and swiping behavior.
The point of capturing profile attribute
distributions is so that we can easily
calculate the compatibility between user
preferences and Unmet user profiles.
These compatibility scores will serve
as the basis for making recommendations.
The system analyzes other users that the
user has previously interacted with and
then builds a structured model in the
hope of capturing the preferences of the
user.
The result is a numerical score for new
users that helps predict the level of
interest I user may have in them.
So to sum it up,
build a preference model for each user
based on their history and profile
features.
Use that preference model to calculate
similarity scores with unmet users.
Then for each user,
create a ranked recommendation list based
on the similarity score is calculated
in the previous step. Yes,
it's cold and calculated,
but the guy's got a cuddle
somehow to improve accuracy,
we can consider a weighting
scheme for the attributes.
Attributes could be
initially weighted randomly.
Then after gathering messaging behavior,
these weights could be slowly
tuned towards the user's
preferences by learning,
say a neural network model,
optimize through gradient descent,
but that's just one way
to do recommendations.
There are many other ways and
the literature here is extensive.
We can expect more services to implement
this kind of feature as the data shows
that people want to spend
less time swiping and more
time connecting with humans
in real life.
In fact,
human connection has become a somewhat
luxury good in 2019 in this age of screen
based interaction.
Anything that can have us spend less
time on screens and more time in person
with humans is beneficial for our health.
Yo, do you want to go outside for a bit?
Totally.
I'll meet you in fantasy forest.
So in the meantime while swipe culture
still exists and we haven't yet seen AI
that's good enough at recommendations
to be able to pick a most compatible
partner with very high accuracy,
we can automate the swiping
process using computer vision.
I found this app on get hub
called Tinder automation.
It's a simple script that lets you access
the Tinder API to swipe left or right
programmatically.
The first step is to create a
labeled Dataset by swiping yourself.
As we manually swiped
through each profile.
It will each image to a likes
folder or a dislikes folder.
After a few hours of Swiping,
we'll have collected over 10,000 images.
Perfect to train a model on this
is now a classification problem and
convolutional neural networks linked to
how they work in the video description
have proven to be supremely useful at
extracting a large enough amount of
features from images to be able to
detect the difference between two labels
automatically likes and dislikes.
In our case,
a simple CNN built with carrots will
do the trick and because our Dataset is
relatively small,
we can retrain an existing model called
Vgg 19 trained on millions of images to
leverage what it's learned previously on
our own dataset and improve our overall
predictive capability.
Once trained,
our CNN will have learned what I
find attractive and what I don't.
Now we will automate the process
of swiping on attractive partners.
We can now just let this run and after
a few hours we'll have the list of
matches setting as time in the discovery
process that we can instead use to
cause havoc in grand theft auto. We can
use AI to automate the discovery process,
but the next step is to give off a good
first impression to your matches and it
turns out AI can help us with that to
dating. APPS are somewhat superficial.
Users are asked to judge each other
based off of a single picture and a short
bio,
which makes it difficult to take history,
personality and character into account.
It's indeed a game,
so we want to play it well and the way
to do this is to approach it as a data
scientist.
We can find several studies online by
dating sites and research institutions
that have derived insights about what
makes an optimal profile that we can
incorporate into our own profile.
Things like making sure
the bio isn't too long.
The profile pic doesn't include
other people in it, no sunglasses,
avoiding using the term woke,
et Cetera, things like that.
Besides the generic advice.
If we want to get more detailed,
we can perform exploratory data analysis
on our own Tinder data using the Tinder
Api.
Looking at a heat map of messaging,
it seems like 9:00 PM on Sunday is the
best time to swipe for the most matches
and generally messages that are more
wordy are more likely to get a response.
Some apps are already using AI for
first impressions. Tinder, for example,
has a feature called smart photos
that alternates the images.
It shows on newer profiles and tracks
which images get the most rights swipes.
It builds this data over
time and gradually refines
the image order until the
highest performing images up first.
When someone views your profile,
it builds a data set to
learn from on the fly.
Another tool for this is photofeeler,
which uses humans to rate your photos
and AI to monitor boat quality,
detect fraud,
and optimize the accuracy of test results.
These tools will help
optimize our pictures, but in
order to optimize our bios,
we can find a collection
of existing Tinder.
Bio's perhaps hire humans via Amazon's
mechanical Turk service to label each
attractive or not attractive.
Then train a simple text classifier on it
to judge if a bio is attractive or not.
When we create our own bio,
we can then classify it to see if
it's quality or not. In this way,
AI can help us make the
best first impression in any
dating app with an optimal
bio and profile pic, but when it
comes to first impressions in person,
we have to think of something clever to
say, right? Yes, but just for the Lols,
I generated some pickup lines using
Google's newly released Burt model.
Burt was trained on lots of existing
text data and we can retrain just the top
layer of it on our pickup lines
to have it start generating texts.
Detailed video on how that works in
the video description. Thanks Ai.
Now we've used an AI to help us with
discovering a partner and making a good
first impression. It's time for the
last part of the pipeline. Intimacy.
Ai Can help humans communicate their needs
and desires with their partner better.
For example,
British dating APP love flutter uses
AI to analyze chats in real time to
determine compatibility and gently
nudge users to meet if it feels they're
getting along really well.
The voice operated dating app called
aim helps set up a time for a phone call
between you and your match and even gives
you advice for your first date based
on what it knows about the other person.
It also reminds you to ask questions
about the things that are important to you
during the date as well.
Afterwards the APP checks in with both
parties to see how it went and recommends
whether they should continue
to see each other afterwards.
We can envision this as
a multi component system.
It first learns both user preferences
to predict points of attraction between
them using collaborative filtering.
Then it can output the results in a plain
English way by feeding the results to
a generative language model.
Remember the Black Mirror episode?
Hang the DJ Black Mirror is just reality.
Dr Khai Thu least stated
at the end of his book,
Ai Superpowers that the one thing
humans can do, that no machine can,
is love and be loved.
Ai could theoretically get to the
point where it could develop romantic
relationships with other humans,
allow her and full 5 cents virtual reality
could synthetically help us feel the
feelings of desire and pleasure that
we get from otherwise traditional human
relationships. But is that something
we want? The desire for love,
intimacy and trust and connection is
human machine learning tools can help make
it easier for all of us to achieve
these desires with other humans.
Define more loving,
more trusting,
more connected relationships with
other imperfect conscious beings.
And until we're able to replicate
consciousness in a machine,
if that turns out to be possible,
it's best to build tools that facilitate
human connection rather than trying to
replace it with technology.
Thus,
there are three things to remember from
this video. Ai Can help optimize time,
investment compatibility, assessment
and intimacy in human relationships.
Techniques like collaborative filtering
can learn how to optimally match users
based on compatibility and both generative
and classification models can help
with the process of discovery.
First Impressions and communication.
You think a machine will
be able to love some day?
Let me know in the comment section and
please subscribe for more programming
videos. For now, I'm going to love
myself, so thanks for watching.